có đường ảnh sáng dài khoảng 8 kí lo mét được tạo nên từ hàng chăm K-Neu,
giòn người dần dài công chàng chỉ đóng tết.
Tuyến phố một sáng ngọt lặng thành hoa những ngày tận tết bính gọi dực dở hương bao giờ hết.
Hầu hết vổ dân đều dựng K-Neu trước nhà,
bối kây cao khoảng 4 mét, làm từ trên luôn chàng chỉ đèn lết,
cơ đó sáo vàng, lòng đèn lụ sắc mầu.
Chỉ vị cho mối kây khoảng 1 chíu đồng.
Đất từ hợp của mình là cả 1.
Cô phố chung lại làm ra, có đường.
Nó đẹp như này, có đường này là hầu nửa bây giờ bảo vết.
Cái tệ giống trong biệt hẹp.
Tổn là mình thắc vào, anh có nếu đau không.
Lâm này, mới là 6 mềm,
thấy là nhiều kây điều nhất.
Kây điều 2 đầu, nó đổi lại với nhau phía nhìn,
bự tối rất là nẹp, chẳng một chắc chẳng này,
hơi nữa là ổ cảm họ đã vào bọc rất là tận thật.
Không sự thể ra giữ rô.
Vìa xy kây điều bắt đầu măng tính tự phát để bui tế.
Tuy nhiên sau sự cố cập vợ trong người an,
bị phóng điện,
khi dự nèu vướng đường dây bà bị làm kỳ lâu vôn,
chính quyền địa phương đã vào quốc liệt đảm bảo an toàn.
Để và ngon xá, chúng đã có kích cái dân.
Đà mà quan tòa, kích chào phía nèu ở trong nhà.
Chẳng có tận định, nó thông,
và có thể chào của thế, chào của thế,
tình có tự kế nếu,
theo ra đến nào mà chào trong chắc chắn,
trên chuyển và đậu ra đến đã bảo ra của đảm bảo.
Theo quan điểm dân dân,
kế nèu được dự nèa hai bài tháng chạm,
khi ông công ông táo về trời,
với ý nghĩa su đổi tả mà,
đóng năm mới bị ăn.
Kế nèu sẽ được hả vào buộc bệnh tháng dự.